To wrap up the shot creation process, one of the things I just want to take a quick
tangent on is the concept of staying organized.
So if I jump back to our scene here, and I've got our SEQ 105 EX open, so the sequence
that we've been building here, you notice that as we've been adding actors to the
sequence itself, they just essentially just, you know, they coalesce in our sequence
browser here, but we don't really have any other organization outside of that.
So if we started adding a lot more things to this, of course it would, you know, sort
by alphabetical, but if we've got a lot of things in this sequence, that's going to
be a little difficult trying to scroll through and find all the things that we need.
So one of the handy features that we can take advantage of is creating folders as
well as colorizing those.
So it's just easily more recognizable what's in those folders, and of course we can roll
them up to keep things organized.
So to do that, I'm just going to simply right click and do add folder, and I'll
just name this one Cinema, and what I can do is drag my Cinema Camera actor into
the Cinema folder, and of course at any point I can change my color by simply right
clicking set folder, and we'll do something like a yellow.
I'll go ahead and right click, add another folder, and I'll call this animations,
or you could do characters, whatever it is that, you know, helps you stay organized.
My recommendation is whatever you do name them, make sure that it's very clear as
to the intent for that particular folder.
So I can just drag my character in here, same thing, right click, and set color, and
we'll do something like a hot pink.
So you'll see in our final sequence, we've created a Cinema folder, Characters folder,
Lighting folder, and Events for our final sequence.
Now I'm going to go ahead and jump here just to a few recommendations when it comes
to additional organization.
So setting up your project, again we talked about this early on in this class, that
it's important to think through how your sequences are going to be built, you know,
how the final game is going to be built, how these things are going to be used, and
creating an organization structure for the project that works best for you.
Now in this particular one, we are using, so in this particular example, we're using
sublevels.
So in this case we have a foreground, effects, geo, lighting, within our persistent level.
Not going to go into too much detail about sublevels, but this is a great organizational
tool for being able to load content in, take content out.
Obviously this may change if you're using something like World Partition, or you're
using other things where you may not have this, but fundamentally speaking, you're using,
in this case the sublevels, as a container just to keep that content together.
So it's easy to determine when things should or shouldn't be seen, or again, let's
just say that, you know, our game, I don't know, some futuristic space port, and there's
a merchant room, and we have a lot of, you know, sequences that take place in this.
So we have a sublevel that is fully dressed, but we don't have it fully dressed during
gameplay because of performance reasons.
Just an example, you could do that, but one of the things to keep in mind, again,
this is just a suggestion, is with your naming conventions in the sublevels, just consider
how you're naming them.
So if you use SEQ, that's a common delineation that you're, it's something for sequences,
right?
You could do BPs for blueprints, effects, post process, again, we could organize our world
or our sublevels in such a fashion where, again, make sure that whatever you do name
it is it's readily clear and apparent the intent behind that.
When it comes to our content browser and an outliner, I absolutely recommend keeping
things clustered together, again, where it does make sense.
So looking at our outliner, so starting on the left, you'll see that we have our
actors grouped together, we have our assets, we have our environment lights, keeping a
clean folder structure just is going to make life easier and ultimately is a time saver
when you're going and digging for, okay, I've got to go find this actor that's in
the world.
Well, if you just have all of your content just rooted in the, the, the base of it,
you could be on a scavenger hunt for several minutes trying to find it versus if you group
again in this case, all of your actors together in the actors folder, great way
to stay organized.
The other thing is in your content browser that we do want to keep our cinematics together.
Now, again, depending on your project and your folder structure, which you do want
to determine early on, I would highly recommend keeping those cinematics in its own separate
folder and not interdispersing those between other like level folders, maps, folders,
content folders, et cetera, keep them together.
If you recall too, so if I jump back to our level real quick, if you remember that
we did have this ability to create a level sequence with shots and that will, you know,
kind of pre-build things out for us by default, that's going to create subfolders within
a cinematics folder.
So if you're looking for a place to start, create one of those, see the folder structure
that's created automatically through that.
And if you want to replicate it for your projects or modify it as you see fit is totally
fine.
Fundamentally speaking and principally speaking, just make sure that you're organizing your
content in such a fashion that it's easy to find what's going on and you don't have
to go on a massive scavenger hunt for it.
One of the other things that we talked about, which we aren't covering in this class,
but is using sub-scene tracks within our sequence.
Now, if you recall too, that I had talked about that, you know, when you create a sequence,
so the actual content piece itself inside of the engine, when you create a sequence,
how you use it fundamentally changes how it works.
So in this case, if we look at this shot right here, we have our shot tracks, which we're
familiar with, but you'll notice down here that we have an animation tracks, VFX track,
camera track, lighting, and sound.
These are all individual sequences.
So we have a sequence when to this case, sub scene sequence, a one or a sequence one,
that's a sequence MK anim track is another sequence.
And then so on and so forth for all these.
So when we drag those sequences in, they may add them as a sequence.
If I go back here, so I'm going to take again, my, um, the sequence we've been working
with the one of five VX.
And I right click, I can do a sub sequence track.
And if I add this, you'll see here, all we have to do.
So let me just actually jump to our nine Oh five.
If I drag this sub scene on here, you'll see it adds it, which is not what we want,
but I can click this little plus and then grab any of these.
And you'll see now I get that sub scene track.
And if I double click it, you'll see that I enter into that sequence.
So again, let's go ahead and just delete this.
So it's not there, but by using sub, uh, sub scene tracks, you can keep your shot organization
extremely tight.
Now in this case, do recommend breaking it up by effectively departments, right?
And the animation department and the effects camera, lighting, and sound department.
And because these are individual sequences, it means that, you know, animation can be
working, have these files checked out in source control at the exact same time that
camera lighting sound or any other, you know, department that has access to this can have
those checked as well.
So you can be working simultaneously on a shot and get the work done that you need
to submit it.
And it's not going to block anybody else.
So again, this is a great way to keep your, your, your actual sequence organized.
And it's such a fashion where again, you can work collaboratively with other departments.
So again, this is just so sub scenes broken out.
So you can see in here, this is even further granularity.
So our animation track actually has the meerkat.
So one character, the Eagle, and then the egg.
And of course these are sub scene tracks as well.
And if you were to open these and go into them, you would actually see essentially what
we have seen here is you see those individual actors, you see the animations, et cetera.
So again, just another layer of granularity.
You can nest this, which just gives you further granular control.
Or again, let's just say that for the sake of argument on this one, that, you know,
there's a very specific animator who's doing the meerkat animations.
And there's a very specific, you know, animator doing the Eagle animations.
Not a problem.
They can be working at the exact same time.
The Eagle animator would check out the Eagle anim track, and then the meerkat animator
would check out this one.
No problems.
You're not blocking anybody.
And you can just roll through creating the actual shot itself.
One of the other tips that I want to bring up is your workspace layout.
So if I jump back to the editor, this is essentially what we've been working in this
entire time.
So I've got, um, in this case, my content browser docked on the left side here, my sequence
at the bottom, and then a dual pane setup of my perspective on this.
So I have a free moving camera.
And then of course, you know, if our shot is active, which I'll do this, I can see
the actual shot on the right.
You can modify your layouts just by simply dragging off any of these little pins.
So for example, if I brought up my place actors, you'll see that I can drag this off.
I can snap it where need be.
We'll snap it to the end here.
I can close it.
You can do whatever layouts you want to.
I do recommend, especially when working with sequencer, you can see how just on a
single monitor, things can get a little tight and compacted.
So you absolutely could tear off additional panels.
So if I go up to window viewports, I could tear off another one, maybe have it on a
reference monitor.
I could open up various different tools.
We talked about like take recorder, sequencer, et cetera.
So get a layout that works well for you.
And then one of the really cool things is that we can actually go into window and
save this layout.
Cool part two is that this is an individual file that we can take with us to any other
machines.
So say for example, we have a development machine back at our desk that we're working
on, whoever layout we absolutely love.
And then we've got an actual live set.
Maybe we're doing motion capture.
I can simply copy those settings files, take it to the other computer, load them, and
I have my layout and vice versa.
So choosing a layout that works well for you is highly recommended.
Now we've included a couple just as example.
So here you see where our content browser sequencer side by side shot.
Here's take recorder again, really depends on your setup, the resolution available on
your screen.
If you use an ultra wide or regular screens, whatever it is that you want to, you take
any of those panels, dock them.
You can save that layout, et cetera, and reload it.
So again, here's just a suggestion for a single monitor layout.
So if you're using only one, if you're using dual monitor again, I highly
recommend using duals.
And then again, at any point you can just save those layouts, um, and load them a couple
other tips and resources for you.
So, uh, with sequencer here are just some hotkeys.
I'll leave this up on screen a little bit.
You can pause it, take a screenshot, something just to help you move a little bit faster
in that workflow.
There's also the Fortnite white paper, which is very handy, even though that, um, it
is a few years old.
Now there are some great tips and tricks when it comes to setting up and creating your
sequences for real time things, which game development is real time.
So this is a great white paper to read through.
You'll probably pick up some good tips and tricks, um, as well as some layout, some
organization and just some like general workflow best practices.
So I highly recommend reading through this.
And of course, there's always the documentation, which is very well outlined when it comes
to talking about cinematic sequencer using cinematic sequences, nesting, et cetera, lots
of good information in there if you need to dive deeper.
So this will wrap up the sequencer introduction for game development to recap real quick,
what we've covered.
So we've gone over some of the basics of sequencer of how to use the sequencer tools,
how to organize your structure, and then how to create a sequence, add actors, add
animations, and then tweak them as need be to get the shot and the results that you
want.
So thanks for sticking along.
See you in the next video.